hey guys ted florento here live in uh
centennial hills currently 9 30 wanted
to give you a quick weather update from
uh the northwest park valley behind me
here you can see the lights from the
strip lighting up the clouds so that is
south of us here at the las vegas strip
where you can see
it very well lit up from
all the lights down there as everybody's
getting ready to welcome in
2022 quick update on the big wins we had
earlier this happened right around the 6
30 7 30 hour the strongest wind gusts
reported was 59 miles per hour at read
international that's huge remember your
low grade hurricane force wind and a low
grade uh category one hurricane is 74
miles per hour so that was uh that was
quite high 48 reportedly up here in
centennial hills for the wind gusts
right around the seven o'clock hour i
should say the 6 30 hour as well sam
boyd stadium down there near wetlands
park reporting a wind gust of 49 40 for
summerlin for you
and 45
uh for the strip where uh michael yo and
nikki are at right now were um
our our current set is for uh our new
year's eve broadcast jeffrey watching
bianca everybody else uh everybody else
jumping on shelly appreciate it roy
thanks for watching so uh currently
outside at this 9 30 hour i want to
report some of our latest wind gusts you
can see some of the trees still moving
here behind me but not nearly as strong
as earlier we're not going to see those
winds like that the rest of the night
happy new year to you too troy joanne
thank you so much so i want to show you
some some current uh wind speeds right
now reporting a uh
a of
a
gust right now of 21 while 24 miles per
hour at read international gust up to 31
at sunrise manor north las vegas
reporting a gust of 26 24 for anthem so
winds are not as strong as earlier what
we talked about is once the
cold front passes through the winds
behind it typically are not as strong
winds are subsiding more and more as we
get through the evening all right
temperatures right now are in the high
40s at this hour but it feels more like
40 degrees at this hour due to the wind
chills that are gusting up up to 25 to
30 like we've been pointed out to you
earlier as we get through the evening
the winds are still going to be blowing
it's going to feel more wind chills are
going to feel more like the 30s okay
closer to freezing by the time we get to
midnight
arnie happy new year to you stephanie
thank you so much too so
right now we do have those winds like we
said still blowing this hour
there were some sprinkles light showers
that came through earlier as well very
isolated very spotty we're not going to
see that though by midnight not going to
have an issue as far as rain goes for
midnight so we want to let you know
about that the big story of course is
going to be the wind chills and the
winds now we talked about uh lori thanks
for joining us tracy thanks for joining
us we talked about whether the fireworks
will fire off now we have been i've been
doing this since 2004 uh covering
fremont street covering new year's eve
this year i'm off but i'm still giving
you your weather updates because i
promised i i'd do that for you because
of the winds um
we still have lit off those fireworks
all right so uh we're not gonna have the
45
50 mile per hour gusts like we had
earlier that of course would be an issue
lighting on fireworks right now those
sustained winds are up to about almost
20 miles per hour with your gusts up to
30
at this hour so it it's not up to me but
most likely they'll probably light up
the fireworks again not up to me but uh
it seems like more tolerable to light
off those fireworks i knew that it would
be an
issue as far as winds go earlier today
but like i said in those graphics i you
probably see me tweet out and put out on
instagram wind gusts are closer to 30 by
time we got to 8 o'clock and midnight
and that's what we're seeing outside
right now
so i just wanted to give you a quick
weather update currently at 9 30 at this
hour don't forget to keep watching eight
news now my boy michael yo my buddy he's
uh he's he's on right now along with
nikki uh and they're they're both doing
the new year's eve broadcast uh so enjoy
that on eight news now and uh if you
have any any questions feel free to
write on the bottom i'll answer them as
best i can in the meantime happy new
year guys and uh we'll see you at the
beginning of the year on eight news now
i'll give you another weather update
later on don't forget to follow me also
on social media on twitter and also on
instagram and facebook
have a good night